[Music]
you look like her butt's a security
guard well
oh no something's wrong guess who's back
guessing
yeah can i guess what he's mad about can
i guess what he's mad about sorry sure
sure school okay this one's gonna be
probably school shooting you know
oh is he crying for the kids
yeah yeah good guess
you're both partially wrong
and also racism
[Music]
[Applause]
buddy this isn't healthy
this this isn't healthy right
for anyone
can we do a counter video where we uh
make fun of him for exploiting dead kids
for views
not a terrible idea
[Music]
[Applause]
sure
you've lost me on your white [ __ ] as
though you have a culture look at
yourselves you want me to be like you
oh he's mad at white people for this
white people uh-huh
the guy was literally named payton but
what oh wait no no i'm sorry that was
last week's news thing that was that was
our fault
sorry
[ __ ] tucker
oh tucker
oh he's mad at tucker
like i said you were partially right but
somehow wow this is all over this is all
over the place isn't it
yeah he's not done either your parents
handed you everything
like everybody at cal and cable that i
saw
the elite white fox who talked like
birds you know shakes you know what
talking about nice teeth yeah talk like
birds though what does that even mean
he said talk about twitter right
yeah talk like birds
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
look i'm not being an [ __ ] look i'm
not trying to make it anyone's worst day
at their job ever
[Laughter]
but
does this [ __ ]
know what the [ __ ] he's saying because i
have no idea what that sentence was i'm
not even trying to be an [ __ ] here
hey [ __ ] oh kitty bye bye you goddamn
die on me
applause it says applause
can we have a dramatic reading of the
tts that's another
dramatic reading of the uh of the closed
captions i mean i i would love to but i
can't this look it says applause
well you can meet him and then we'll
just read
your it okay fine fair enough we could
do that but see it's not picking that up
though let's even fix this up no but it
did say something about birds and mice
that it did
no nothing here you're you're not you're
not anything other than children
fine white boy applause
oh the big man on the block upper bench
you've lost me on your white
as though you have a culture look at
yourselves you want me to be like you
you've got that piece of [ __ ] tucker
your parents handed you
everything like everybody at helen cable
that i saw
the elite white who talk like birds
you don't say
oh kitty
[Music]
[Laughter]
i don't know what he's saying i don't
know we don't know what he's saying here
guys i'm sorry we would keep doing it i
have no idea
intermission
95
of black people have white genes in them
because of real critical way race theory
you [ __ ]
which is all you southerners great to
black people i had kids and those are
the shits you threw in jail cause you're
too [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] down your [ __ ]
you stupid less than a man [ __ ]
have i ever seen you in the streets i'll
spin piss on you
like you're a stupid cowardly life sack
of
intermission
oh intermission
you [ __ ] tucker
foxtas
you say one more [ __ ] thing about
minorities that you become by enemy
every single news anchor on fox
and if i ever see you in the street
[ __ ]
i has no amount of applause that's gonna
save you from me got a tucker
that's tucker's fault tucker goes to
prison for the rest of his white
privileged life we're talking [ __ ]
[ __ ] and if somebody listens to him and
kill that's what happens all lawyers and
psychologists agree with me or you have
nothing
now
i'll pray to god and kill you all
after you [ __ ] with me god
[Music]
the [ __ ]
out of your panty ass [ __ ]
[Applause]
this has been another segment of
mastertard theater
proudly brought to you by viewers like
you
and the goldman sachs corporation
[Music]
that was [ __ ]
hilarious
so we may have to to start doing that
with some other ones i think that that
is [ __ ] wonderful we could all take
turns doing some some live oh yeah just
mute it and [ __ ] read it i was a
little disappointed that you didn't
throw the word inward in after a couple
of those bleeps
it would have worked perfectly and i'm a
little disappointed to be fair semper
we still got to keep it we still got to
keep it accurate damian mckinley
wouldn't say that he wouldn't he
wouldn't say that that dramatic reading
was amazing bravo sir bravo bravo
thank you
look at his face right there look at
that right there
look at that
guy squizzy hi guys you know me damie
mckinley easy going
[Music]
[Laughter]
i like long yells on the beach
there there's two more of this
no there's not no there's not yes yes
there is should i go to his channel and
find them there's two more of them
directly after this in the same rant
okay
theater uh i can lower the which one all
police are cowards
oh okay directly next to this one
oh hey all social like russians you call
yourself oligarchs like your noble right
is money do that did that give you
access to getting no ability oh no
that's that wasn't the school i can
lower the this one you mean
see you're not going to deal with it oh
it's directly after that
this one's the one that's directly after
right this one
oh no it wouldn't be the one
to the left oh this sorry all right okay
that's the one
hold on hold on all right play the music
get your masterpiece voice on yes yes
yes yes
here we go
[Music]
it's on
does it really matter you're projecting
yourselves and the way
oh i can't remember you should be
protecting children to the why because
harvard says this more kids died this
year than police
[ __ ] cowards
i hope we're clear
about how [ __ ] cowardly you are
oh may god suck your dick
what
because after that you die
[Music]
you're not the best of me
oh [ __ ] you
you're dead
don't you ever [ __ ] with me again
a man is almost this and you're a [ __ ]
dude he has the craziest [ __ ] eyes
he's a lunatic hold on i gotta hear him
this year the police you [ __ ]
cowards
i hope we're clear
about how [ __ ] cowardly you are
mankind suck your dick
what a weird threat right jj work your
magic on that one
so the subs were accurate
yeah yes
wait a second
but jj has him and me yelling it
no but wait a second
why will god suck your what
well he's saying that he hopes god sucks
your dick
so because that's the last thing you're
ever going to be able to have fun with
because that's the next line play the
next line
okay because after that you die got it
man
i chatted
i know it's going to be hard but try and
match his mouth you know oh that's
that's really subtle
i know it's going to be hard but
i'm saying when he does the inaudible
[ __ ]
oh hey all social like russians you call
yourself oligarchs like you're noble
right
does money do that did that give you
access to being nobility
do you like killing you creating
children
[Music]
hello russians you weak [ __ ] like
you're mad
hey bad [ __ ]
tell me like you're a man then why are
you killing kids i'm stealing ukrainians
great are you stu
do not have enough [ __ ] leg to grow your
own [ __ ] grave like a man why are you
stealing other people's [ __ ]
[Music]
russian military
i know opps can see me
look into my mouth and suck my dick
all russians doing ops
your sick twisted mental ill [ __ ]
i hope the creator comes and [ __ ] you
may you die
screaming and then you go to hell
forever that's russian ops for what you
did to my country you stupid [ __ ] cuz
russ is dumb as [ __ ] look at yourselves
you're stupid you're not cool your women
hate you and they're all county [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] master magic so that i could
give them money you [ __ ]
tell me russian military what exactly
about your incest menaced culture as
what i want to be like [ __ ]
soviet fox because i'm red todd and
you're all blue [ __ ]
russian lobster fuzzies fast stop stop
right
there read that again
russian lobster fuzzies
[Laughter]
i'm gonna start calling people russian
monster fuzzies i i think i know what he
wanted to say when he said fuzzies